you know a lot of people thought the
second trailer was coming out today i
don't know why they did so many people
were saying it and i got so many
messages last night guys i don't think
it is i don't want to stress about it so
many people were searching about it but
here we are today and this is funny
because we did a video the other day
saying did sodi just confirmed toby and
andrew are in spiderman no way home
something else got upset today we got
cosmic wonder here spider warren as we
like to call him did tom holland just
confirm that toby maguire is in here
and then you know when tom holland
starts running that uncharted mouth of
his
you know it's something a little meaty
you got to read into what that guy's
always saying and by the way uh cosmic
wonder he's been doing a lot more work
on his actual and personal website doing
these articles and such and the really
great reads i would go check it out i
know john's read a bunch always it's the
only thing i read now
[Music]
i think tom holland
just confirmed
that toby maguire or andrew garfield
is in
spider-man no way home what's going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder i'm warren thompson and we did
not get a spider-man no way home trailer
2 today but if you watch my video i did
a few days ago you would have known that
we knew it wasn't going to be coming out
today as sad as that is but the future
both have egos for knowing in the next
couple days
some really
really interesting news about spider-man
knowing home from entertainment weekly
involving a scene with tom holland
aunt may
john favreau
and another superhero
get this in this description of this
scene they actually have to specify
which version of the character they are
talking about this combined with some
leaks going around and some insider
information i have received leads us to
believe that in this scene it is toby
maguire's spider-man that has joined tom
holland marissa tome and jon favreau's
characters in spider-man no way home so
let's dive into it the article actually
is pretty revealing and i think it's
actually a marketing technique by sony
which i will talk about later on but
let's dive into what this says and i'm
just going to go over it and read it
word by word so get this it starts off
by saying throughout his time in the
spider-man suit tom holland has got to
shoot some spectacular stuff in the
upcoming spider-man no way home the
actor tells empire that he filmed one of
the coolest scenes i've ever shot a
sequence including a character he wasn't
at liberty to divulge so right off the
bat when you hear tom holland can't
mention who a character is in a scene
you automatically think well this has
got to be toby mcguire's character or
andrew garfield's character but they
actually give us more to believe that
this is indeed the case it goes on to
say what he could say is that the scene
features his peter parker and i stress
that it literally says his peter parker
marissa tomei's aunt may and john
fabro's happy hogan along with a mystery
fourth character
let me just stress how they are having
to specify which characters these are
they literally say his peter parker
that's the most telling part
he said his peter parker why say that
come on man
come on tom's getting antsy come
he wants the cat out of the bag as much
as we do and i think we all know why
they have to specify which peter parker
this is here's what tom holland had to
say about the scene it's four people
sitting at a table having a conversation
about what it's like to be a superhero
that's definitely the scene that has to
be the the leaked scene that has been
going around where they're talking about
like how when they're exchanging
dialogue and that's probably when this
the moment uncle ben is brought up if
any of these leaks were to be believed
how they would talk about uncle ben and
i feel like that would describing a
dinner table discussion of what it means
to be a hero with great power comes
great responsibility that would probably
be the best moment to do that scene and
perhaps it might be reflective of the
many conversations that rosemary harris
would have with toby maguire
in uh those spider-man movies yeah i
mean come on
who else said maybe it's daredevil i
don't know who else to be talking to i
just wanted
all the links that have been coming out
the other day we watched the scene my
brother and i and our jaws were on the
floor okay can we really expect him to
be talking about anyone besides toby or
andrew tom holland literally said they
were talking about what it's like to be
a superhero which means that fourth
person has to be a superhero himself or
herself but i truly believe that it is
toby rumor has it right now that we are
actually going to get the great power
great responsibility line in this scene
and i stress that right now it's just a
rumor but according to this rumor it's
going to be toby maguire spider-man
sitting down with tom holland spider-man
aunt may and happy and tobey maguire
spider-man is going to be talking to tom
holland and he's going to say peter with
great power comes great responsibility
get ready
told me that if they're ready to attract
what we are going to get i think
everybody is going to lose their minds i
know i am i'll probably cry not going to
lie i've seen a few people kind of in
the industry online tweeting about this
and i asked a personal social media so
you heard this but they did not confirm
that that's exactly what's happening so
take it as a rumor for right now but man
do i want this rumor to be true now
here's something that is really really
interesting empire magazine goes along
to say cue all the speculation about who
that fourth chair belongs to
another
or might it hint at the long rumored
crossover between holland's peter parker
and those played by andrew garfield and
toby maguire empire magazine says it
they wouldn't know
who it is they wouldn't the fact that
they are leaning heavily into teas and
man tom hall you uh i don't know if they
they they might have let him say that
they might have i might have been like
it's cool you could say it i think half
this stuff has to be like intentional
viral marketing at this point i mean we
don't even have a poster yet i imagine
that second trailer comes out we see
some toby and andrew and then we start
getting posters with all three of them
on it so you know what if in that
trailer we hear toby say with great
power comes great responsibility then
i'll freak out and ten minutes after
we're done recording i will say i wish
they say they say
empire can't really say much that sony
doesn't want them to say sony most
likely approved this article before it
went out and they definitely approved
what tom holland said before he said it
yeah and if tom holland said something
before he's talking
to the public they would make sure that
that didn't happen they have not
addressed the other two spider-man yet
but they keep letting other people hint
at it think about it who could this
really be it could be matt murdock but
from what i've been told he's only in
one scene and he's not suiting up as a
superhero and from what i've been told i
don't think it's this scene and the
thought of it being another avenger i
think that's just a diversion i don't
think that's going to happen at all we
already have enough going on sure i'm on
your page plus dr strange and plus two
other spiderman right and not to mention
the reddit user my time to shine hello
who has been accurate about previous
links in the past this person even went
online today and said he's talking about
toby and like i said this person has
been 100 accurate to my knowledge about
the leaks
so there's no reason to doubt that this
person is accurate about it being toby
so literally everything points to this
fourth person being toby maguire
spider-man plus who else is gonna make
tom holland and his brother's jaw drop
while watching this scene and i'm just
truly excited to see this scene hear
that passion in your voice the other two
spider-man even though they're not
confirmed
it's pretty much all but confirmed at
this point but let me know what you
think about this article about what tom
holland said in the comments down below
do you think it could be somebody else
besides toby or i'll throw and andrew as
well or do you think it's toby or andrew
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all of the latest
spider-man and mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram twitter
or tick tock and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof wow
we're for awakening i
feel like our odds of getting the second
trailer are going to be this thursday
when the magazine releases or the
weekend after eternals like the monday
or tuesday after eternals comes out
that's that's just where my mind is
going but we'll keep our finger on the
pulse but subscribe click that
notification bell because we're gonna do
our absolute best to be on top of it i
expect a lot of spider-man stuff this
week
i expect a lot just saying
all right guys get ready to get annoyed
by all those notification bells from us
as we mix it in with
korean movies and shows